when Mark was arrested for drugs
possession and dealing he thought his
life was over but
Rodrigo duterte was President of the
Philippines and his Crackdown on drugs
resulted in the killing of thousands of
suspects
but Mark says he's found Hope even
though he's in prison
we have given the opportunity to to
continue our studies
we can't reveal Mark's identity as his
case is still in court along with dozens
of other detainees he's studying for a
college degree in a building next to
himself it was built in 2017 with the
help of a non-profit organization during
the height of the so-called warn drugs
in duterte's Hometown Davao City
members at this jail are pioneering the
use of Education to reform drug
offenders and other criminals it's also
the first prison in Asia to offer
college degrees now it's one of the
first in the Philippines to
institutionalize a reading program
president Ferdinand Marcus Jr has taken
an alternative approach to narcotics
crimes
together with the United Nations his
government plans to install more
libraries like this in at least a dozen
more detention centers
this is just python parcel of the
ecosystem that we need to provide for
them to have an enabling environment
later on especially once they get
outside of jail and they will no longer
come back here inside our jail
facilities
time spent in the library and studying
is considered good behavior which in
turn reduces time and detention
Philippine jails are overcrowded by
nearly 400 percent
human rights Advocates welcome the
education initiative but insist duterte
be held accountable there's no way you
can approach the drug problem in the
Philippines in a Humane and human rights
way without taking into account
accountability for past abuses and
particularly in the past seven years
to that end they have been urging the
government to submit to an investigation
by the international criminal court but
the Justice secretary is defiant you use
the due process here the legal process
here you're going to take over our
justice system
none of the local drugs cases being
prosecuted or investigated however have
implicated duterte victims families say
it shows they can't count on Philippine
courts to deliver Justice barnabilo Al
Jazeera Davao City Southern Philippines